this video was made possible by
curiosity stream watch thousands of
documentaries for free for 30 days at
the link in the description airlines can
make a lot of money by flying to the
right places British Airways for example
long ago cemented themselves as the
leader on the London Heathrow to New
York JFK route and flying between these
two airports now earns them over 1
billion dollars per year that's more
than any airline makes on any other
route in the world conversely though
airlines can lose a lot of money by
flying to the wrong places
American Airlines for example recently
canceled their Chicago to Beijing flight
as it was losing them tens of millions
of dollars per year now the fact that
this route failed might be puzzling
considering it flew between the world's
50th and the world's seventh largest
city even more they were flying the 787
Dreamliner the smallest plane they could
on this route nonetheless it was truly a
financial disaster the airline said that
in terms of annual revenue the route was
eighty million dollars away from their
target the truth is that deciding where
to fly is a lot more complicated than
pairing up the largest cities it's an
art that people spend their whole lives
mastering and the difference between an
airline that's good at route planning
and one that's bad at is can be the
difference between a profitable airline
and a defunct one in 2015 the big three
airlines in the u.s. American Delta and
United launched 101 new routes
these included everything from United's
new 30-minute regional flight between
Chicago and Kalamazoo to Delta's new
trans-pacific service between Los
Angeles and Shanghai some of these 101
survived some did not of the routes that
Delta launched in 2015 about 70% still
fly today there were some big noticeable
cancellations from the 2015 launched
routes including Orlando to South Paulo
New York to Manchester and Philadelphia
to London meanwhile American Airlines
did a little better with 76% of their
2015 routes surviving today still they
clearly had some expensive failures with
routes like Dallas taquito Miami to
Frankfurt and New York to Birmingham
United Airlines though has a noticeably
higher 85% of those 2015 routes still
flying today the only four routes from
2015 that didn't work out where Houston
to Peoria Newark to Newcastle Dulles
milene and denver to San Jose now it's
worth noting that the survival of routes
is not the one definitive measure of how
good airlines are at route planning
different companies might have different
risk tolerances they might wait out a
route longer there are a lot of other
factors involved but there is other
evidence that United is good at route
planning there are a number of
destinations that United is the sole
American airline to operate - just
looking at long-haul destinations that
includes Melbourne Tahiti Taipei Chengdu
Delhi Mumbai Naples Porto and Stockholm
in some of these cases there might be
just enough traffic to support one US
airline flying there and United got
there first in addition there are plenty
of routes that United flies without
non-stop competition like Denver to
Tokyo Houston to Rio de Janeiro TC to
Zurich and Chicago to Edinburgh many of
these potentially riskier routes have
survived for years so they're clearly
good at route planning they're clearly
good at finding the opportunities both
big and small according to United the
two major factors they look at when
deciding where to fly are how many
people want to go there and how much are
they willing to pay these questions are
easy to ask but extremely difficult to
answer that's why it's people's whole
jobs for figuring out how many people
want to go to a place the airline itself
has a decent amount of data the majority
of new united routes are destinations
already served by another one of their
hubs for example one of the routes that
United added in 2015 was from Denver to
Southwest Oregon Regional Airport which
was already served by its San Francisco
hub given that United Rd had data on how
many people flew there from Denver via
San Francisco and would therefore take a
nonstop flight United also flies to a
number of places non-stop from Denver
that it doesn't from San Francisco such
as Albuquerque Sioux Falls in Wichita
that would now have a one stop option -
Southwest Oregon Regional Airport rather
than a to stop for brand new
destinations though especially long haul
ones United doesn't have its own
passenger figures so they have to figure
out how many people want to go there
through other means one of the great
assets that travel booking sites like
Expedia Google flights and Skyscanner
have is that they know where people want
to fly they know which city pairs people
search for flights between and many
sell this incredibly valuable data to
market research companies and Airlines
Skyscanner for example knows that
190,000 people a year search for a
flight between Birmingham and Hong Kong
four hundred and twenty thousand people
a year search for a flight between Delhi
and Auckland 1.1 million people a year
search for a flight between Bangkok and
Barcelona and 1.4 million people a year
search for a flight between London and
Kochi these all represent big
opportunities that airlines have yet to
act on people are still making these
trips but having to connect creating a
nonstop flight on any of these routes
would capture a decent amount of the
traffic the reason some of these popular
routes do not have a nonstop service
though comes down to that second factor
how much people are willing to pay
people usually pay a premium to fly on
nonstop flights but there's a maximum -
how much extra people will pay for the
convenience in October 2017 United
launched a new non-stop route from Los
Angeles to Singapore to much fanfare
this would be the airline's longest ever
route the only nonstop connection
between the two cities and they expected
it to do great the problem though was
the competition currently brown ship
connecting flights between Los Angeles
and Singapore are on sale for as little
as four hundred and forty four dollars
at the time the United was flying this
route they were supposedly even less
United just couldn't come close to the
prices that others were offering and
exactly a year after this route was
launched it was canceled it wasn't a
complete failure they ended up just
adding a second frequency to Singapore
from San Francisco but it is an example
of a route that looked great on paper
but didn't work out in reality it was a
similar reason that likely led to the
cancellation of the American flight from
Chicago to Beijing mentioned at the
beginning it was just too tough to
compete against the low fares of Asian
Airlines and as a result Americans
planes were crossing the Pacific empty
in all airlines need to figure out what
people will pay for a route to figure
out if it's profitable and also if it's
going to be the most profitable route
they can add part of the reason why
American and Delta might not have added
a nonstop flight to Singapore is because
they can make more money using the same
plane elsewhere United essentially has
now used up four of its planes to fly
its two daily flights to Singapore
they're charging a minimum of about $800
to fly round trip on this 16-hour flight
whereas from the East Coast
United is also charging about $800 to
fly round-trip on their six-hour flight
from DC to London airlines need to
consider whether out of a whole world of
options they're picking the best one
when adding a route beyond these two
main factors there are others involved
in whether or not a route will work
financially for example while a certain
route might work for one airline the
exact same route might not work for
another from Australia there are three
routes to mainland China operated by
Australian Airlines Qantas from Sydney
to Beijing and Shanghai and Jetstar from
Melbourne to Zhengzhou meanwhile from
mainland China there are 43 routes to
Australia operated by Chinese Airlines
this extreme imbalance exists because
people tend to prefer to fly on Airlines
from their home country especially in
cases like this where the language is
different there are far more Chinese
traveling to Australia Australians
traveling to China so therefore there
are far more Chinese airlines flying to
Australia than vice-versa
of course there are other factors
involved such as given the lower cost of
living in China Chinese airlines have
lower labor costs and are therefore able
to offer lower fares but when an airline
is figuring out whether a route will
work the nationality and directionality
of travellers does matter sometimes
though a route is launched that just
doesn't make financial sense at least
independently sometimes Airlines
launched routes primarily to slow the
advance of a competitor for example on
September 6 2017 Wow air the Icelandic
budget airline announced that they would
start flying from Reykjavik to Dallas
less than a week later Iceland air the
other major Icelandic airline announced
that they too would start flying from
Reykjavik to Dallas about a month after
that
American Airlines announced that they
would also start flying to wreak Ubik
from Dallas now Dallas is very much a
fortress hub for American Airlines that
is they control a huge percentage of the
market share there and they want it to
stay that way they didn't want their
customers to start flying on WoW or
Iceland air to Iceland or more
importantly beyond to Europe well
Iceland has seen a significant increase
in tourism traffic over the past decade
there are a few signs signaling that
this route addition might have
more for competitive purposes than
because it was the best financial choice
independently the first is the
suspicious timing announcing quite soon
after the two other airline's did and
the other is that it really doesn't make
sense for Americans one and only Iceland
flight to leave from Dallas this
requires all connecting travelers from
the east half of the country to
backtrack to Dallas if they want to fly
on American to Iceland the airline has
in recent years concentrated most of
their transatlantic flights going to
leisure oriented destinations such as
Iceland to their Philadelphia hub but in
this case it was clearly most likely
more about stopping Wow and Iceland air
in this American was successful both of
its competitors have sent stopped flying
to Dallas well this and other similar
routes might not make money themselves
overall there a right decision for the
company since they can force a
competitor out of the market and in this
case passengers that might have
connected on Wow or Iceland air from
Dallas to Europe
we now take Americans transatlantic
flights so once all that analysis
happens once an airline decides that
it's a good idea to launch a route it
still doesn't mean that an airline can
go ahead and start flying obviously they
need a spare plane that can either come
from another route cancellation or
through a new aircraft delivery for
example United's new route from San
Francisco to Tahiti with relatively low
demand required its smallest long-haul
plane the 787-8 Dreamliner one of those
only became available when a new 77 nine
was delivered from Boeing that replaced
an older 77 age on the busier San
Francisco to Munich route airlines also
named gate space and some busy airports
Atlantic slot for many international
routes Airlines also need government
approval to begin a new flight there's
plenty more uninteresting bureaucracy
but then some time usually years after
an airline first examines whether a
route will make sense the first plane
will take off between those two airports
no matter how much work is put into
analyzing whether a route will work
reality always has unforeseen variables
the true test of whether a route will
work is actually flying the route once
that happens airlines will evaluate its
performance if it's making enough money
it will keep flying if it's not you
will not this is all part of Airlines
continuous cycle of planning launching
and evaluating routes in order to find
the few that can actually turn a profit
in this notoriously financially
difficult industry if you're watching
this video there are two things that you
almost certainly like documentaries and
aviation therefore I would imagine you
would like this documentary on curiosity
stream about the whole process that it
takes to make an Airbus a380 wing it's a
fascinating look at all the work that
goes into producing what is perhaps the
most important element of that plane
this is one of over 2,400 documentaries
that you can watch on curiosity stream
which is compatible with iOS Android
Xbox one
chromecast Apple TV and plenty more
platforms it's also quite reasonably
priced and only $2.99 per month for
unlimited access better yet by signing
up at curiosity Stream comm slash
Wendover and using the code Wendover you
can watch all their documentaries for
free for 30 days and you'll be
supporting Wendover while you're at it